exams all sorts of unnecessary uh
aggravation uh this is gonna cause and i
want to emphasize to everybody why i
think those strikes are so wrong
so wrong and so unnecessary don't forget
throughout the pandemic the uk
government supported the railway
industry to the tune of 16 billion
pounds we kept our railways going again
quite rightly too we supported our
railway workers and their families we
supported the whole industry it cost
every family in this country thousands
and thousands of pounds to do that and
we are making as everybody knows bigger
investments longer term investments in
railways than any previous government
the integrated royal plan alone is worth
96 billion pounds what we're doing is
truly transformational making a
generational uh investment in railways
and we love it we believe in our
railways we believe in our railway
infrastructure as a vital part of
leveling up across the whole of the of
the country uh and i'm proud to be uh
inaugurating northern powerhouse
wellness as i was proud by the way to be
the mayor of london who started cross
ones across braille uh in
our country as well and that is what uh
we are doing but if we're going to do
these colossal investments as we are as
we must we've got to have reform and
we're going to have a form in the way
that the realm will work and it cannot
be right but
some ticket officers i think are selling
you know roughly one ticket per hour
we need to get those staff out from
behind
plate glass onto the platforms
interacting with passengers and with
customers in the way that they they want
to do
and we need the union barracks to sit
down with the network network well and
the train companies and and get on with
it and
we need i'm afraid everybody and i say
this to the country as a whole and we
need to get ready to to stay
the course to stay in the course because
these reforms these improvements in the
way we run our railways are in the
interest of the traveling public they
will help to cut costs for fair payers
up and down the country but they're also
in the interest of the railways of
railway workers and their families